so what about the following question Oh
so Alejandra dragon wants to know how
would you describe Littlefinger and
virus relationships my whiteness how
would you describe Littlefinger and
virus relationship adversarial both of
them know a lot about the other one
including some very damaging things so
they're in a essentially a stalemate
because each one knows that he revealed
what he news about the other one then
the other one would reciprocate then
they could both be destroyed so they're
kind of locked in a certain stalemate
I think Littlefinger has a better idea
of what Varys wants than Varys
that's an idea of what Littlefinger
wants Littlefinger is an agent of chaos
who likes to be unpredictable and
succeeds in men okay thank you
which of your characters would you say
is the most suitable to be a leader
nowadays and white which of my
characters would be a leader in this day
and age yes well you know probably
tyrion tyrion is very smart
he's also very ruthless sadly which you
need i do necessarily who would be a
beloved leader but you know he he has
the intellectual ability to do it he has
a certain understanding of politics and
he has a lot of experience in the dark
side of humanity so he wouldn't be too
naive for the job
he might be good choice I agree very
good
now Danny Danny would also be an
interesting choice if we could bring her
dragons along the recent American
election might have turned out very
different if Hillary Clinton had dragons
oh I love this one as well this was sent
by emo Yvonne Medina Zaragoza and she
says what was the Epiphany that tragedy
- devoting your life to writing should
be when was the Epiphany that dragged
you to devoting your life to writing it
was my inability to do anything else
[Laughter]
[Applause]
when I was quite young of course I was a
big comic book fan and and you know Mike
my goal in life at that time was to be
you know Batman first I had to become a
billionaire so I could be a billionaire
playboy and then I had to exercise a lot
to get in really good shape so I could
swing on bat ropes and punch people out
well press us of that that didn't seem
really feasible and then I thought maybe
I would be Green Lantern instead so
because all I had to do was find a ring
for that it took a lot less exercise and
I looked around for ring but there was
no rings to be found and no radioactive
spiders bit me so I was just stuck with
making up stories which is something
I've done since I was a little kid and I
was pretty good at making up stories so
I've continued to make up stories until
this this for a day okay
[Music]
[Applause]
okay constancy acevedo clintus i have no
royal lineage having cleared that up
what advice would you give me to ask
Sansa out on a date well you know if you
have no nobility I don't think the stark
family would would be too interested in
your dating Sansa all the marriages were
kind of arranged back then they were
political alliances between Great Houses
and they had to bring some advantage and
you know Sansa didn't fool around with
peasant boys so that wasn't going to
happen now if you're talking about
asking sophie turner out on a date
that's all another issue she's a modern
21st century woman from Great Britain
and a beautiful one but I tried to run
social calendar so I can't help it air
guy okay well these were sent by quoting
a lot of our labels if you could change
anything in a game of rome's what would
that be
if I could change anything yes I would I
would have all the books done by now
that would be that would be good I would
like to be in that I don't know why do I
do that though because I'm a slow writer
and I as I get older I seem to be
getting slower not faster
I am hoping you know some of you who
have are familiar with my working career
know that I did do a number of novels
before Game of Thrones dying a light
Seba dream the Armageddon read
with each of those novels there was a
point where I could see the end in sight
you know it was like I had pressed at
the top of the hill and now I was
rushing toward the finish line and
whenever that happened I sped up
considerably I'm hoping at some point
that happened son taken on a song of ice
and fire that at some point you know
with dant densive with a winds of winter
and then dreamless spring that I will
see that I will see the finish line and
suddenly the work will start going much
faster just as it did on those earlier
books but so far it hasn't done it is
there anything I would actually change
about what is in the books themselves I
don't know I think in retrospect maybe I
should have made rob of viewpoint
character in the early books a lot of
people kind of figured out that's where
rob was gonna die just because he didn't
have any chapters and I don't like to be
predictable and that would have allowed
me to do it on the other end we made the
books along there too so I don't know
that's one that I played with from from
time to time what in the world is going
on out there
good traffic Mexican traffic that's just
traffic okay
someone else hurry to get somewhere so
if you had a dragon you can clear that
right up
[Laughter]